fabulous fabbi Carole wanna the Rockets
from an America and here we're going to
look at five of his most amazing moves
remember to like this video and
subscribe to the chest comm channel if
you're not already to subscribe
what on earth are you doing all this
brilliant content for free come on get
on the case
anyway see how many of the moves you can
find we've got five stunning
possibilities here and I hope you enjoy
my pick on to example number one this
first example is fab II playing against
X feed a world champion at Roseland
calamari off he has the white pieces he
has free dangerous pieces hanging around
that little bear King on a 7 now
remember do play along and see if you
can find the moose what was the stunning
move here that forced a winning attack
pause if you need to well
rook d7 oh yeah the rook just slides its
way into the position threatening a
devastating attack on the c7 square but
you might be thinking can't black just
take that rook will he did and now comes
the second blow Bishop to a six white
threatens Queen - b7 checkmate and after
King takes a 6 you only way to avoid
that the a8 square is now free so Queen
a8 is checkmate stunning stuff there
really impressive visual sort of shall
we say connection to the chessboard
let's move on to example number 2 fabbi
is victim in this game is none other
than the great American hit Gloria
Nakamura I guess the guys are big rivals
Hikaru has just pushed his pawn to e5
given a little bit of fall key for key
there stabby stabby for key for key and
the next move reminds me of another very
famous Queen sacrifice and this is ready
for the expert players out there maybe
in the comments below you can mention
this Queen sacrifice who played it as
white it also happened on the f6 square
who was it an old old player from the
Russian
sort of area you might get it can you
get it well Queen takes f6 is the next
stunning move here and this is a
beautiful positional sacrifice giving up
the Queen we all love a queen sack don't
we and after Bishop takes f6 white now
has this fantastic square for his horsey
now you don't see many gems saying that
in the middle of the board
it's a knight don't call it horsies
don't get bad habits
maybe you should be listening to me then
but hey ho and after Queen to d8
defending the bishop here the other
night jumps in to f5 and you can see
white has brilliant pieces here rook b8
Knight takes f6 check and this allows
the rook to dive in and even though
white only has a knight and a bishop for
the Queen you can see that White's
pieces have dominating the boy and often
the initiative is much more poor
important than material that's the case
here and white went on to win this game
a bit long for this series but this is a
beautiful Queen sacrifice on to example
number three this next example is fab e
Fabio B with the white pieces against
Emmanuel Berg a very strong Grandmaster
from Sweden and it really reminds me
this this bang-bang-bang it's like a
hammer knocking down the wall the black
wall around the king in numerous little
places here reminds me of Macau at his
greatest Tao loved attacking he loved
ripping his opponents King apart and
fabbi here definitely shows a bit of
towel like Flair towel of course being
an ex-world champion
maybe fabbi well one day who knows so
can you see how white did the job here
well the first blow is the brilliant
Knight takes f7 drawing the black King
out into the open the black King has to
take this knife and one hammer blow is
now met by another hammer blow what is
the next brilliant move here rook takes
c6 and this draws that black King even
further out into the open if the rook
has not taken White has ideas are coming
in
loads of checks on these two squares and
there's numerous possibilities here in
the game black played Knight takes e5
let's just have a quick look see what
happens if he would have taken that rook
you can clearly see the king is very
naked in the middle of the board and
make it King is not a good king
it might get arrested for exposure
though don't make your King naked and
here Bishop c4 check forces the Kingford
routes and now we simply have Queen h5
check and after something like g5 Queen
f7 check that the hunt continues Knight
to f6 and you can see this king is
running around and of course quite a
complicated variation but Queen c4 is
the final checkmate and this is really
combining brilliance calculation with
brilliant vision after night to c5 as in
the game white continued by rook takes
d6 and now Queens where for check and
the king has to defend the rook of wise
White's going to be two pawns up and
here the checks continue and now King to
d7 checks continue let's blow after blow
and here Queen f5 check and you can see
they just keep on coming and now rook
takes a 6 a brilliant move there and the
point being here black resigns if Queen
takes we have Bishop takes c6 check
winning a lot of material and the game
and a very nice idea it might look like
black has a bit of a a back check there
but how better way to win a game than by
meeting a check with a check and that
could have been an even more beautiful
finish to this brilliant attack now
fabbi has the black pieces and again
Queen sacrifices are so much fun to play
obviously only when they work I've often
sacrificed my queen there and it hasn't
been too good but its next example is
very very nice is fabbi with the black
pieces and here he just plays pawn takes
c3 offering his Queen on d8 which has to
be taken
and now the black rook slides him with
ideas are coming to the back rank with a
deadly check and you can see the
combination here of Bishop Bishop rook
and pawn a really flooding through
White's position is that she does remind
me slightly of one of Bobby Fischer's
most amazing games his game of the
century in the way that he got his
Bishop to a sinless square and offered
his queen and now after Queen to c2
trying to cover the D 1 square a takes B
for these pawns become absolute
powerhouses Knight d2 and this is rather
desperate because after pawn takes d2
you can see why it's given up a lot of
material and now rook to AAA trying to
force a way into the back rank the rooks
were exchanged off white rather greedily
grabbed the pawn but now rook a1 check
Bishop to c1 and be free and after Queen
d1 one more blow here Bishop takes b2
and white resigns so very nice
combination there and you know sometimes
Queens are not worth as much as the
little guys don't get carried away of
your Queens but if you are giving up
your queen make sure you count clear
summarize you look like a damn fool and
that's only my job and been fine goals
job this last example is a lovely
demonstration of how to rip your
opponent's king apart in chess you had
to really be rather violent to be a
strong player those stories are one
English grandmaster watching wildlife
shows of wolves riffing literally
ripping up deers before we play chess to
get in the mood for his game can you
guess who that was what wasn't me by the
way anyway what is the move here rook to
f5 I love this move it's a very simplest
move on the surface because we're
getting rid of the porn and the knight
the only two pieces really that are
defending the black King the rook will
also take the knight if it's not
captured and there's one more great move
here bringing yet another piece to the
attack Knight to d4
if we can win the Queen we will and
after it moves the night even changes
direction and this night takes a very
funny route into f5 we can see Black is
in a lot of trouble nights where four
was tried and white simply removes this
defender takes the bishop with check and
after Knight takes f5 Queen h5 is coming
rooks hg free is coming White has free
very strong pieces attacking and free is
generally the magic number when
attacking a lone King and white goes on
to win in some fashion here King g6
I like this white repeats the position
once basically saying I'm the boss and
after king g6 routes worth one forcing
the Queen away to a bad square here
comes my favorite porn Harry and now the
Queen can't defend g4 anymore so the
Queen snips its way in snips its way and
again and after Knight to h6 black is
losing his queen and losing the game
very nice combinations there from fabbi
so some brilliant combinations which was
your favorite move from those five
examples I quite liked number one who's
going to qualify for the candidates all
these things you should discuss below
maybe it'll be fabulous maybe a little
bit of ding mirin which we're going to
hopefully do a video on soo if you want
to see that video
dude like this video do subscribe to the
chess comm channel really helps chess
calm the best place to find lots of
instructional videos from top
grandmasters and me you know I'm still a
grandmaster maybe not that high but I'm
somewhere on the list so do enjoy and
thank you so much for spending time to
watch this video we're bringing more
players in a jiffy old boy